Richtig, Chat. Auf den Mount Everest.
Tangle. Pork Subscription.
Massive HiIQ Sub.
Du bist schon in der Gruppe?
Kann das sein?
Die Gruppe gibt es erst seit 1 Minute 16.
Aris Modge. Du hast Early Access Group gehabt.
7LQRS.
Weitere HiIQ Sub.
Biggest Brains hier wieder.
Schon was von Bann gehört.
Javascript. Ja.
Ich glaube wir haben sogar ein Video offen von Fireship, was wir gucken wollten.
Oder?
Wir haben das geguckt sogar am Sonntag.
Ich weiß nicht.
Natürlich.
Wie sich das für jede gute Gruppe gehört, Leute.
5 Leute noch, dann mache ich dicht.
Gönnt euch jetzt.
Ich habe meine Gönniamin Woche.
Es gibt so viele dämliche Sprüche dafür.
Gönnt euch die Gruppe.
Dann mache ich aber wirklich dicht.
Der Link.
Den gibt es erst nach Prime Sub.
Ansonsten den Discord.
Wobei Discord habe ich teilweise in letzter Zeit das Gefühl,
dass es mehr Selbsthilfegruppe als Technikgelaber noch.
Manche Leute haben ja echt Probleme.
Denke ich mir immer so.
Wenn ich wirklich richtige Probleme habe,
gehe ich dann in den Discord von Max.
Und hoffe, da ist irgendjemand da.
Der versteht, was ich für Probleme habe.
Ich weiß nicht.
Macht ihr nur.
Wenn es euch hilft, ist gut.
Ich habe zwar einen Bedenken, ob das einem wirklich hilft.
Ich habe mehrere Gruppen.
Ihr wisst, wie das ist.
Eine Gruppe alleine tut ja nicht.
Man muss erst in eine Gruppe.
Dann gibt es noch eine Premium- und VIP-Gruppe.
Du musst dann upgraden.
Von der normalen Gruppe.
Und in die Premium-Gruppe.
Da kommen immer 5 Leute rein.
Und nur einer davon kann upgraden auf die VIP-Gruppe.
Da muss das Business richtig laufen.
Ich habe noch nie verstanden bei diesen Videos.
Beziehungsweise bei diesen...
Werbespots sind es im Endeffekt.
Und aber auch Videos von diesen ganzen Coaches.
Dass da immer noch so viele drauf reinfallen.
Hör auf.
Tier 2 Subscription.
Highest IQ.
Das ist ja nicht plus 10.
Das ist ja schon plus 30 für alle.
Die Mods kümmern sich darum.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum da immer noch Leute drauf reinfallen.
Wir erklären dir, wie du reich wirst.
Ganz im Ernst.
Eine Sache, die ich mich schon seit Ewigkeiten frage.
Welches Interesse hat jemand?
Einen super krassen Trick, wie er reich wird, gefunden hat.
Diesen Trick der ganzen Welt zu erklären.
Das konnte mir noch nie jemand schlüssig erklären.
Und dann kommt am Ende raus.
Es ist einfach alles Scam.
Wer hätte das nur ahnen können.
Leute, morgen früh muss ich wieder aufstehen.
7 Uhr muss ich nach Frankfurt fahren.
Ist gar kein Bock.
Train-Ge.
Muss ich dann machen.
Mit einer deutschen Bahn.
Keck-Business.
Morgen muss ich MonkaDB machen.
Hatten wir da nicht, doch hatten wir.
Morgen, Leute.
Ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Dann ist morgen auf der Arbeit so eine komische Veranstaltung.
Die fängt irgendwie morgens an.
Und geht irgendwie bis mittags.
Keine Ahnung.
Gucken, vielleicht kann ich schon wieder 16 Uhr abhauen.
Ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock.
Keck-Business.
Letztens.
Auf der Arbeit.
Ihr wisst ja.
Ihr kennt ja meine Karriere-Grind-Ambitionen.
Also Leute, ihr wisst ja.
Ich will unbedingt super krass Karriere machen.
Und grinde dafür jeden Tag 24-7.
Und hustle mir einen ab.
So habt ihr mich kennengelernt die letzten 12 Jahre.
13 Jahre sind das schon.
Habe ich recht?
Ihr kennt sicherlich keinen krasseren Karriere-Grinder wie mich.
Zumindest.
Witzigerweise.
Es gibt so eine Veranstaltung.
Nennt sich, glaube ich.
Abteilungsleiter-Sprechstunde oder sowas.
Irgendwie so heißt das.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Und das ist irgendwie einmal im halben Jahr.
Und da kam letztens eine Mail.
Okay, die Anmeldungen sind jetzt offen.
Und ich dachte mir so.
Ja, schön für euch, wenn die Anmeldungen offen sind.
Ich gehe da eh nicht hin.
Und.
Nach ein paar Tagen.
Also nachdem die Anmeldung noch 2 Tage offen war.
Habe ich mal in die Anmeldeliste geguckt.
Übrigens Leute.
Also muss man dazu sagen.
Das ist eine Veranstaltung.
Und wir haben Outlook.
Teams.
50 verschiedene Wikis.
Zeiterfassungssysteme.
Schulungssysteme.
Planungssysteme.
Und mit welchem Tool.
Wird die Teilnehmerliste gepflegt.
Für diese Veranstaltung.
Was meint ihr?
Man hat 30 Tools zur Auswahl.
Die das alles richtig gut können.
Excel! Korrekt.
Excel, aber Moment.
Excel alleine ist es noch nicht.
Noch nicht Excel.
Die eigentliche Kombination ist.
Excel auf einem Windows Share.
Excel auf einem Samba-Laufwerk.
Irgendwo.
Ich weiß nicht.
Du hast 30 Milliarden Tools.
Die alle das gut können.
Sogar gleichzeitig editierbar.
Und dann wird das Excel irgendwo abgelegt.
Na gut.
Wie dem auch sei.
Hat sich seit Jahren bewährt.
Mittlerweile geht das sogar ganz gut.
Kollaboration Excel auf Windows Share.
Aber.
Ich habe dann zumindest.
Mal so just for fun.
Es kam dann nochmal eine Message in Teams.
Leute.
Abteilungsleiter Sprechstunde.
Das war wahrscheinlich letzte Woche Mittwoch.
Nur noch zwei Tage Zeit.
Sich anzumelden.
Okay Leute.
Jetzt ratet mal.
Abteilungsleiter Sprechstunde heißt.
Alle fragen sich wie viel es da gibt.
Acht oder so.
Abteilungsleiter.
Setzen sich mit Fragen und Themen.
So der Leute die sich dort anmelden.
Auseinander und kann ein bisschen schwätzen.
Und was auch immer.
Es gibt insgesamt 45 Plätze.
45 Leute können sich da drin eintragen.
Und teilnehmen.
Was meint ihr.
Wie viele Leute haben sich angemeldet.
Auf diese 45 Plätze.
Zwei Tage vor Anmeldeschluss.
Okay Leute.
Ihr seid gar nicht schlecht.
Ihr seid nicht schlecht.
Die richtige Antwort habe ich noch nicht gelesen.
Aber ihr seid wirklich.
Es bleibt ja nicht mehr viel übrig.
Nee.
Es hat nämlich noch keiner gesagt.
Sechs Leute.
Von 45.
Da sieht man schon mal.
Wie extrem viel Bock die Leute da drauf haben.
So.
Haben sich sechs Leute angemeldet.
Bam Bam Bude.
Danke für den Sub.
Ich hoffe ich habe nichts gesehen.
Potato Bob sicherlich schon.
Modkiss haben den Link zur Gruppe geschickt hoffe ich.
So.
45 Leute angemeldet.
Und jetzt.
Nee.
Du hast das falsch verstanden.
Dort gehen alle Abteilungsleiter hin die wir haben.
Das sind glaube ich acht Stück.
Und es können sich 45 Leute anmelden.
Und mit allen Abteilungsleiter reden.
Oder Themen anbringen.
Die sie gerne besprechen wollen.
So in kleineren Gruppchen.
Mit dem jeweiligen Abteilungsleiter.
So ist das gedacht.
Es sind 45.
Nicht 45 Leute.
45 Plätze frei.
Wo man sich anmelden kann.
So zumindest.
Nachdem wir das geklärt haben.
Dass sich ganze sechs Leute von 45 angemeldet haben.
Dachte ich mir so.
Oh ne.
Ne.
Ich habe keinen Bock.
Und dann schreibt mich ein Kollege an.
Max.
Weißt du was.
Ich habe einen Tipp für dich.
Und er meint so Max.
Falls du es noch nicht mitgekriegt hast.
In zwei Tagen ist Anmeldeschluss.
Für diese halbjährige Abteilungsleiter Sprechstunde.
Geh da doch mal hin.
Das ist sicherlich richtig gut für deine Karriere.
Und dann musste ich ihm erstmal erklären.
Was für ein krasser Karriere Kreisel Grinder ich bin.
Musste ich ihm erstmal erklären.
Dass ich wenig Interesse an.
Irgendwelchen weiterführenden.
Personal.
Und sonst was.
Verantwortungsvollen Aufgaben habe.
Ich will einfach Cloud und Linux Zeug machen.
Bis ich in Rente gehe.
Wobei bis ich in Rente gehe nicht.
Das ist Blödsinn.
Rente gehe ich ja wahrscheinlich mit was weiß ich.
Bis ich keinen Bock mehr habe.
Will ich das machen.
So.
Und jetzt.
Und jetzt kommt der Plottwist.
Plottwist.
Bei der ganzen Sache.
5 Minuten später.
Also ich habe ihm dann erstmal erklärt.
So ne Karriere Grind.
Geht mir nicht auf die Nerven.
Will ich nicht.
So und jetzt kommt der Plottwist.
5 Minuten später.
Nachdem ich dem erklärt habe.
Warum ich da keinen Bock drauf habe.
Übrigens das mit dem Fiat darf ich nicht überlesen.
Da wollte ich tatsächlich was zu sagen.
5 Minuten nachdem ich.
Ihm erklärt habe.
Das ich keinen Bock auf sowas habe.
Weil ich keinen Bock auf Karriere Grind habe.
Kam der Kollege.
Mit dem ich von der alten Arbeit.
Zur neuen Arbeit gewechselt bin.
Also den ich schon jahrelang kenne.
Und meint Max.
Sag mal.
Eigentlich habe ich ja keinen Bock.
Aber.
Also.
Was hältst du davon.
Wenn wir auf diese Abteilungsleitersprechstunde gehen.
Ne.
Ich habe keine Lust da drauf.
Hör mal auf.
Ja aber er wird sich das ja mal angucken.
Aber allein will er da auch nicht hin.
Weil was soll er da erzählen.
Aber okay.
Meinetwegen weil du es bist.
Und jetzt gehe ich morgen.
Auf die Abteilungsleitersprechstunde.
Das wird was.
Da habe ich überhaupt.
Ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Wehe der kommt morgen nicht.
Wenn der morgen nicht da ist.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Fuß gebrochen oder so.
Dann gehe ich da auch nicht hin.
Ich habe so keinen Bock Leute.
Ich mag solche Veranstaltungen halt null.
Na gut.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal wie es läuft.
Ich wollte zu meinem Auto was erzählen kurz.
Hier.
Wie ist eigentlich dein Fahrzeug zu deinem Elektro-Fiat?
Alles gut?
Ja.
Was willst du wissen?
Ich weiß gar nicht was ich dir großartig erzählen soll.
Ich bin heute wieder zum Ausflug.
Kreisel.
Kreislaufen gefahren mit dem Auto.
Umweltfreundlich.
So wie sich das gehört.
Warum scrollt der Chat darunter.
Achso weil er auf Fiat stand.
Ja.
Was willst du wissen?
Sesam.
Sesam Sam.
Also.
Ich meine ich habe ja schon öfters was darüber erzählt.
Es ist kein Vergleich zu meinem Auto davor.
Ich meine ich hatte.
Für alle die es immer noch nicht wissen.
Ich hatte das beste Auto.
Überhaupt.
Ever.
Jemals.
Jemals gemacht.
Davor.
Und zwar ein grünen.
2001er.
Oh.
GG.
Die G-Eats.
Ja.
Das.
Also.
Da sind die Grills am Start.
So.
Das hatte ich davor.
Und.
Das ist kein Vergleich dazu.
Ich meine.
Das Auto ist von 2001.
Ihr könnt euch überlegen.
Das Ding hatte nix.
Das hatte keine Displays.
Für irgendwas.
Das hatte.
Das hatte noch.
Das hatte alles analoge.
Geschwindigkeitsanzeigen.
Tankfüllungsanzeigen.
Und.
Alles mögliche.
War da oldschool.
Ich bin mir jetzt nach.
Ich habe das Auto zwar schon ein Jahr nicht mehr.
Ich bin mir nicht mal sicher.
Ob das überhaupt schon.
Irgendwie sowas wie Servolenkung hatte.
Oder so.
Ich.
Glaube.
Schon.
Ich bin mir da aber nicht sicher.
Liefs.
Liefs wie ein Uhrwerk.
Nee.
Also.
Der hatte jetzt zunehmend Probleme.
Deswegen habe ich mir auch ein neues Auto gekauft.
Und.
Weil ich Bock hatte.
Mal auf ein neues.
Modernes Auto.
Zumindest.
Insgesamt.
Und.
Hat.
Als Sesamsamen was geschrieben.
Ja.
Wollte.
Wissen.
Ob das Auto.
Irgendwelche.
Probleme.
Macht.
So ist es natürlich nice.
Wenn alles.
Funktioniert.
Macht.
Er.
Lass mal überlegen.
Macht.
Er.
Viert.
Naja.
Gut.
Der.
Hat.
So ein.
Der.
Hat.
So ein.
Paar.
Probleme.
Weil.
Noch.
Zu dunkel.
Zu nebelig.
Zu sonst was.
Aber es war auch okay.
Solange das Ding.
Einfach nicht.
Besser als.
Dass es einfach.
Random bremst.
Ich hatte es übrigens einmal.
Dass das Auto.
Random.
Gebremst hat.
Aber ich kann mir.
Ich kann mir jetzt.
Erklären.
Warum es das gemacht hat.
Einmal.
Jetzt in einem Jahr.
Und da war.
Da war das Auto.
Hatte wahrscheinlich.
Sogar.
Irgendwo.
Noch recht.
Dort zu bremsen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ob ich das.
Irgendwie noch.
Richtig zusammen.
Da stand.
So ne Ampel.
Davor sind Häuser.
Und da stand.
Ein paar Tonnen rum.
Und.
Da ist.
Sind.
Zwei.
Zwei Kinder.
Ich glaube.
Einer war noch.
Auf dem Roller.
Und der andere ist gelaufen.
Sind.
Auf die Ampel.
Hinter den Tonnen.
Raus.
Auf die Ampel.
Zugelaufen.
Halt.
Relativ.
Schnell.
Die.
Ampel.
Und.
Leute.
Laufen.
Zügig.
Auf die Ampel.
Zu.
Da hat er auf einmal.
Wild angefangen.
Zu piepsen.
Und.
Der hat gar nicht gebremst.
Stimmt übrigens.
Gar nicht.
Hat nicht gebremst.
Hat nur gepiepst.
Der hat.
Waren gepiepst.
Und ich hab dann gebremst.
Oder ich hab dann.
Langsamer.
Gemacht.
Das war das einzige.
Mal.
Dass ich.
Irgendwie Probleme.
Mit den Assistenzsystemen.
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich.
Wenn die auf die Straße.
Gesprungen.
Wäre.
Gar nicht bremsen können.
Aber die sah nicht so aus.
Als springen sie auf die Straße.
Die sah halt nur aus.
Als.
Sind sie mit ihrem Roller.
Halt.
Gefahren.
Und dann.
Werden sie halt.
An der Ampel angehalten.
Sind ja auch angehalten.
Also.
Das einzige.
Was da.
Was da gewesen ist.
Welche Fiat.
Führst du.
Fährst den.
Ich hab mir.
So ein Teil hier.
Gekauft.
Fiat 500 E.
Etwas günstiger.
Gewesen.
Konfigurieren.
Und.
Kaufen.
Auf geht's.
Nein.
Fortfahren.
Alter.
Sind die Dinger.
Teuer.
Mittlerweile.
Ich weiß nicht mal genau.
Was ich bezahlt habe.
Ich hab's euch aber erzählt.
Die hat noch so ein Konfigurator.
Äh.
Ey.
Warum gibt's da.
Das kann ich.
Der E.
Ach.
Was auch immer.
Fiat Zeit.
Ist echt.
Pepega.
Ist es nicht.
Sogar das gleiche.
Sarix.
Ja.
Fiat.
Fiat 500 E.
Dachte.
Du hättest gemietet.
Oder genießt.
Ne.
Hab ich überlegt.
Ob ich das machen soll.
Hab ich wirklich überlegt.
Aber.
Ich bin dann.
Ich bin.
Das.
Auto.
Probefahren.
Gegangen.
Hier in der Nähe.
Und da haben die mir erzählt.
Hier.
Max.
Das ist ein.
Ist ein Vorführauto.
In dem du gerade drinne hockst.
Ist das.
Ich glaube.
Vorführautos.
Dürfen ja irgendwie.
Bloß sechs Monate.
In Benutzung sein.
Ja.
Ist ja quasi.
Ist.
Läuft er.
Ab.
Da hab ich das hier.
Und wie sieht es aus.
Und da haben die gesagt.
Ja.
Dann gibt es das natürlich auch billiger.
Und da haben wir ein bisschen rum.
Rum gemacht.
Was.
Preis.
Den Preis angeht.
Was.
Letzte.
Preis.
Haben wir gemacht.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Was ich bezahlt habe.
Ich habe es euch erzählt.
Ich.
Ich glaube.
Ungefähr.
25.000 Euro.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ich habe es verdrängt.
So.
Irgendwie.
Was in dem Dreh.
25.000 Euro.
Normal.
Neu.
Kostet glaube ich.
38.000.
Aber nicht exakt.
In der Ausstattung.
Aber Neukauf.
Das sieht keiner.
Zumal.
Es gab letztes Jahr.
Auch noch.
Habe ich auch schon wieder vergessen.
Wie viel das war.
Hier noch.
Elektroauto.
Prämie oben drauf.
Da habe ich mir gedacht.
Weißt du was.
Max.
Du hast dir vor über.
Oder sagen wir mal.
Vor.
20.
Jahren.
Zu letzten Auto geholt.
Kannst ja auch mal wieder Auto holen.
Ja.
Ne.
Ist nett.
Nett.
Nett von dem.
Ist es denn eigentlich nicht.
Dein Ziel.
Das Geld zu sparen.
Aufgrund der Ersparten.
Früher in Rente zu gehen.
Naja.
Mache ich doch.
Ich habe meinen.
ETF.
Ich gebe.
Für fast nichts Geld aus.
Gar nicht.
Weil ich nicht Geld ausgeben will.
Sondern.
Weil zu wenig gibt.
Wo ich.
Für.
Geld.
Oder.
Angemessen halte.
Geld auszugeben.
Ich habe ein Haus geerbt.
Ich verdiene 100k plus im Jahr.
Auf 5 Tage gerechnet.
Ich habe genug Geld.
Auf.
Also.
Ich.
Werde nicht bis zur Rente arbeiten.
Das kann ich dir sagen.
Das kann ich dir sicher sagen.
Garantiert nicht.
Ich mache das so lange.
Bis ich keinen Bock.
Mehr habe.
Zu.
Zur.
Not.
Kann ich ja immer noch ein bisschen was.
Mit YouTube und Twitch verdienen.
Wenn es hart auf hart kommen sollte.
Aber.
So aktuell.
Aktueller Finanzstatus.
Sieht wirklich.
Echt.
Ganz.
Brauchbar.
Aus.
Ja.
Meine.
ETF Stonks.
Haben auch richtig gestoppt.
Wieder.
Die.
Letzten.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Scalable.
Was.
Haben meine Stonks.
Gemacht.
Ja.
Plus.
1214 Euro.
Richtig.
Stonks.
Letzten.
Monat.
Eineinhalb Monate.
Ging es.
Richtig.
Rauf.
Ich glaube.
In Scalable kann man gar keine Prozent anzeigen lassen.
Kann das sein.
Und Leute.
Ich glaube.
Ich brauche.
Ich brauche auch bald einen zweiten Account.
Bis wann ist Einlagensicherung.
Oder.
Bis wann ist die Kohle sicher.
Die man bei einem Anbieter hat.
50.000 oder 100.000.
200.000.
Nee.
100.000.
Okay.
Dann ist noch ein bisschen hin.
Bei Aktien gilt das glaube ich nicht.
Ja gut.
Das stimmt wohl.
Weil die Aktien gehören einem ja.
Glaube ich.
Weil.
Mir gehören ja die Aktien.
Also ist im Prinzip ja egal ob dieser Traderladen Pleite geht.
Ja.
Irgendwie so.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja.
Da gehe ich auch nicht hin.
Ey.
Wenn der morgen nicht auftaucht.
Ja.
Joa.
So.
Ja.
Ergemiss.
Removes all Apple watches and bands from its watch...
Ach ja.
Das haben wir uns doch erst vor zwei Tagen angeguckt, Lul.
Dach...
Moment!
Nee.
Ich hab's sogar noch auf.
Wann denn Fiat flashen?
Naja.
Wi-wi-wir getten.
Wir getten da hin.
Ja?
Ich bin nämlich schon am überlegen, ob ich nicht...
Ähm...
Eingebaut ein Entertainment System rumbasteln soll.
Gibt ja ein paar
Third-Party
Addons schon
Okay
Heiner bremmen, das weiß ich Bescheid. Wenn mich einer fragt, woher weißt du das eigentlich? Twitch-Chat hat es gesagt
Läuft da ein Android drauf? Ja, korrekt
Android
Oder wie im Heise-Forum die Leute schreiben würden, ich habe einen Androiden im Auto
Heise-Forum ist auch richtig krasse Boomer-Party
Ich habe einen Androiden im Auto
Richtig, richtig Painz-Champ, oder?
Richtig Painz-Champ
Das sind die gleichen Leute, die sagen
Mini-Weich-Window
Golam-Forum ist fast genauso, das sind die gleichen Leute. Golam-Forum ist nicht ganz so viel los wie im Heise-Forum
Royal TS. Ist Royal TS nicht ein Hamburger?
Oh ja, wir haben auf der Arbeit auch Mobile-X-Term, richtige Schrott-Software
Kannst du mal den Unterschied zwischen Node-Port und Cluster-IP erklären?
Ja
Also
Das eine ist ein Port auf dem jeweiligen Kubernetes-Node und das andere ist eine
Cluster-weit gültige
Warum heißt das eigentlich IP?
Cluster-weit gültige Endpoint ist der richtige Wort, glaube ich. Endpoint
Ist ja eine Mischung aus, also das geht ja um Services, geht ja um Kubernetes-Services
Endpoint ist im Kubernetes-Fach-Jargon, glaube ich, der korrekte
der korrekte Begriff hierfür, also warum auch immer das Cluster-IP heißt, weiß ich nicht. Das ist eine eindeutige IP für deinen Service
Cluster-weit IP plus Port
Also ein Endpoint für den Service
Und das ist halt Node-IP plus einen Random-Port überhalb von 30.000
Node-Port benutzt man tatsächlich relativ selten, also ist meistens Cluster-IP oder Loadbalancer, aber hauptsächlich Cluster-IP
Wie man Modge wird
als besonders high IQ auffallen
Und dann müssen die Modges sagen, weil ich ernenne Leute nicht direkt zum Mod
Dann müssen die Modges sagen, Leute, wir brauchen ein bisschen Verstärkung
Und die und die Leute sind mir im Chat aufgefallen als Leute, die wir für gute Modges halten
Ich entscheide das gar nicht, also ich meine letztendlich unterm Strich, am Ende entscheide ich das immer noch, wer Mod wird
Aber ich nehme einfach die Leute, die die Modges vorschlagen, die wissen es am besten
Ich meine, ich habe ja auch schon ein paar Leute selbst gemoddet, von denen ich denke, okay, die sind richtig
Schlau, was bestimmte Themen angeht, machen auch einen sehr umgänglichen Eindruck, weil die ersten paar Mods muss ich mir ja noch selbst raussuchen, aber
Seitdem verlasse ich mich eigentlich drauf, was die Mods sagen und vorschlagen
Aber ich muss sagen, der Original-Cute-Mod fehlt mir so ein bisschen hier
Geht es doch irgendjemand so?
Der Sebarro müsste mal ein bisschen öfters wieder da sein
Leider ist von Sebarro so wenig zu sehen
Ich glaube, das liegt an zwei Sachen
Entweder ist sein Lehramtsstudium einfach so anstrengend, wobei der auch bald mal fertig sein müsste, wie lange geht denn sowas?
Allzu lang kann das nicht mehr gehen, oder es hat doch geklappt mit seinem Referendar-Grill
Was er da hatte
Und der ist anderweitig beschäftigt
Sagen, Silver, danke für den Sub, vier Monate stellst, ja, dann hast du jetzt glaube ich auch den
nur den Goldkeks
Wird das hier angezeigt?
Ne, Silber ist er noch, drei Monate, Gold ist glaube ich ab sechs Monaten, also im Auto ist das ein Android
Das ist bei Fiat Android Auto überall
Und selbst drauf kannst du mit, ach ne Moment, das ist Android Automotiv, glaube ich, weil Android Auto ist die Client-Anwendung dafür
So rum ist es glaube ich korrekt
Connecten kannst du dich per Carplay oder per Android Auto
Sagt der TÜV eigentlich nix, wenn du Custom-Firmware auf dein Auto flashst, ich flash keine Custom-Firmware auf mein Auto
Was ich mir überlegt habe ist, es gibt so ein paar Third-Party-Add-Ons
Zum Beispiel, dass man eine eigene Rückfahrkamera
anschließen kann, die dann aber auch halt eben umgeschaltet wird
Wenn man rückwärts, wenn man auf den Rückwärts-Button drückt, ich will nicht sagen den Rückwärtsgang einlegen, weil das macht man dort nicht
Man drückt halt einen Knopf für Rückwärtsfahren
Und dadurch kann man, man kann dann auch noch mehrere
Videoquellen anschließen und sowas an das Display, das ist eigentlich ganz nice, das habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich das selbst modde
Aber aktuell habe ich da keinen großartigen Bedarf für, deswegen
Vielleicht schraube ich lieber nicht an meinem Auto rum
Link zum Git-Repo-Eintrag gelassen
Mit Hash von der Firmware
Übrigens, Leute, wisst ihr, was wir demnächst mal machen müssen?
OpenWrt
Wir müssen das hier demnächst mal machen
Ein Auge, ich sehe nichts
Wir müssen das hier beim nächsten Mal machen
Wir müssen den Unify-Access-Point flashen mit OpenWrt
Ich habe ja noch vier Unify-Access-Points, die aktuell im Schrank vergammeln
Und ich wollte es schon lange ausprobieren, wie gut OpenWrt auf diesen Kisten ist
Und dann habe ich mir was überlegt
Willst du mir einen schicken? Nee, will ich nicht
Alles behalten
Und dann habe ich mir nämlich überlegt
Ich bin ja bei O2
Mobile-mäßig
Und da kann man bis zu sieben SIM-Karten kriegen
Und ich habe, glaube ich, 40 GB im Monat
Oder 20, oder 40, viel zu viel
Und ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich mir nicht ein
5G
WLAN-Router
Ins Auto lege
Da habe ich überall WLAN
Ich meine, eigentlich ist es unsinnig, weil
Auch so ziemlich alles
Was ich im Auto dabei habe
Selbst
Eine SIM-Karte drin hat
Aber es ist, glaube ich, doch in manchen Fällen
Ganz praktisch, wenn man
Ordentliches WLAN im Auto hat
Für Geräte ohne SIM-Karte
Ich habe mir nämlich
Zum Beispiel schon überlegt, ob ich nicht
Einen Raspberry Pi fest installieren soll in meinem Auto
Und der muss ja irgendwie ins Internet
Wenn ich darauf zugreifen will
Ein Router
Korrekt
Das ist die Cisco-Aussprache
Dein Auto hat kein Esel
Mit WLAN-Hotspot
Doch, aber nur
Über den offiziellen Tarif, den man bei Fiat
Buchen kann, das sehe ich nicht ein
Also eine SIM-Karte hat das Auto auf jeden Fall
Weil du kannst ja auf Online-Services damit zugreifen
Und von außen aufs Auto zugreifen
Das geht nur über eine SIM-Karte
Und man kann auch einen Hotspot-Service buchen
Warum soll ich das machen, wenn ich 40G
Volumen habe, wo ich kaum was von brauche
Wo Gruppe die Mods schicken dir das?
Nach dem Prime-Sub
Und es passen nur noch
Fünf Leute rein in die Gruppe
Dann mache ich wirklich dicht
Es reicht jetzt langsam
Man muss auch mal gönnen
Aber irgendwann ist auch Schluss
Meinst du, das muss ich wirklich in der Gruppe machen?
Ja, nee
Ich mach das wie die ganzen Gruppenscammer
Wenn im Zweifelsfall wirklich jemand was haben will
Sag ich, sorry, warst du leider zu spät
Ich hab gerade geclosed
Gerade die Gruppe geclosed
Aber du bist der Erste, der wieder rein darf
Sobald ich sie öffne
Ich kann auch nichts machen, die Gruppe ist halt voll jetzt
Live-Coaching
Hab ich doch schon öfters gemacht im Stream
Das ist tatsächlich eine Sache
Wenn man das Live-Coaching nennen kann
Ich hab doch schon öfters
Mal meinen Senf zu
Zu Sachen, die ich noch vor 10 Jahren anders gesehen habe
Oder vor 20 Jahren anders gesehen habe
gegeben
Zum Beispiel hätte ich vor 20 Jahren
Da war ich 20, by the way
So ungefähr
Nie gedacht, dass ich mich mal
Freiwillig bewegen würde täglich
Und dann auch noch
Nicht nur täglich
Über eineinhalb Stunden laufen
Sondern dann alle zwei Tage auch richtig rennen
Sechs plus Kilometer
Hätte ich nie gedacht
Mit 20
Glaub ich nicht, dass du das machst
Ich mein, mir war mit 20 auch schon klar
Dass es gesundheitlich besser wäre
Es zu machen
Aber es heißt noch lange nicht
Dass ich es gemacht hätte
Wie sowas hab ich gesagt
Du hast richtig
Du hast recht
Winzig war ich
Das ist so cringe
Wenn ich das schon ausspreche
Krafttraining auch
Ich will es ja mal nicht übertreiben
Jetzt stellt euch mal vor
Ich hätte jetzt auch richtig krassen Muggis
Und ich würde mir meinen Opel Agila wiederholen
Da könnte ich mich ja von lauter Grills nicht mehr retten
Nee, also Krafttraining nicht
Vielleicht
Überkommt es mich irgendwann mal
Auch ein paar Gewichte zu heben
Aber aktuell habe ich echt
Macht mir das wirklich Spaß
Jeden zweiten Tag hier meine
Runde zu rennen
Und jeden Tag meine eineinhalb Stunden
Zu laufen, das ist wirklich nice
Ich muss sagen
Eine Sache ist wirklich top
Seitdem ich das mache
Also jetzt nicht
Seitdem ich noch zusätzlich rennen gehe
Sondern nachdem ich mich wirklich täglich
Außer Sonntag, vielleicht mal mit Ausnahme
Über eine Stunde, eineinhalb Stunde plus
Bewege
Ich hab fast nichts mehr von den Problemen
Die ich noch vor
Ein paar Jahren hatte
Ich hab keine Kopfschmerzen mehr
Gar nichts, null
Nichts mehr
Mein Blutdruck ist so niedrig
Dass ich fast das Gefühl habe
Da stimmt irgendwas mit dem Gerät nicht
Keine Rückenprobleme
Irgendwelche Verspannungen
Sowas
Keine Schmerzen
Irgendwie hinten im Bein oder so von zu viel gehockt
Und eine Sache muss ich sagen
Wobei
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher woran das liegt
Ob das nicht vielleicht auch an den Prime Subs
Liegt
Wir wissen ja alle
Prime Sub gleich High IQ
Es könnte aber auch sein
Ich weiß nicht was ihr für realistisch erhaltet
Aber
Es könnte auch sein
Das seit ich angefangen habe
Jetzt wirklich alle zwei Tage auch nochmal ordentlich zu rennen
Dass ich mich irgendwie auch
Momentan wieder etwas fitter fühle
Ist nicht so das ich je gesagt hätte
Alter mein Hirn
Funktioniert nicht oder so
Aber mir kommt
Mein Hirn
Ähm
Expandeter vor
Seit ich
Seit ich angefangen habe zu rennen
Es könnte auch an den Prime Subs liegen
Wie gesagt
Hab ich noch nie ausprobiert
Ich weiß nicht ob das OpenWrt kann
Aber OpenWrt kann eine Sache
Die Unify nicht kann
Und Unify keinen Bock hat zu unterstützen
Die ich aber für sehr wichtig halte
Was auch der Grund war warum ich die rausgeschmissen habe
Top Bit Donator
Das weiß ich nicht
Sobald Modgis Status
Käuflich wird
Wenn man das einmal macht
Es läuft aufs Bruder
Ne habe ich nicht
Ne
Hast nen Link
Was ist der beste OpenWrt Router
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Ich habe OpenWrt
Sehr lange nicht mal selbst benutzt
Stimmt Kollege hat da auch mal so ein Gruppenscam
Ne
Ich weiß nicht was mit den Leuten los ist
Ja man kann von der Musik halten was man will
Ihr wisst dass deutscher Rap nicht unbedingt meins ist
Aber dass man auch irgendwie versuchen muss
Seinen Fans so krasses Geld aus der Tasche
Zu ziehen mit irgendwelchen komischen
Ähm
Life Changing
Chatgruppen
Wo man lernt vom Boss wie man das richtig krasse Business macht
Ich weiß nicht
Ja und der hatte auch mal
Irgendwie so ein Fitnessprogramm
Ja das gab es auch
Wobei ich mich lieber
Von Haftbefehl coachen lassen würde
Wie man sich im Frankfurter Ghetto
Richtig bewegt
Dass man nicht auf einmal sich auch wieder
Ne hat er sich ins Bein
Hat er sich ins Bein gestochen
Selbst oder aus Versehen selbst den Fuß geschossen
Eins von beiden war er doch
Er hat es abgesagt weil er das Gescammer nicht leiden konnte
Ja klar
Nachdem der Aufschrei zu groß war vielleicht
Ich bin mir nicht sicher
Ich glaube Haftbefehl hat sich aus Versehen
Den Fuß geschossen
Vor 1-2 Jahren
In die Wade hat er sich geschossen
Hast du was mitbekommen
Von der Triathlon WM
Ja ganz am Rande
Von einer richtig krassen Triathlon Leute
Wie sein letzten Triathlonlauf
Gelaufen ist
Aber sonst habe ich auch nicht viel von mitbekommen
Und das habe ich auch nur mitbekommen
Weil ich in letzter Zeit ein bisschen nach
Ja Jogging Rennen Videos
Gesucht habe auf Youtube
Und jetzt Youtube meint
Ja Max dich interessieren bestimmt auch die aktuellen Ironman Ergebnisse
Oder sowas
Für das Alter ist eine ausreichende Menge an Muskelmaße
Wichtig
Das klingt plausibel
Ja hast du sicherlich recht
Da
Okay das ist glaube ich
Eines der Probleme die mein Vater nicht hat
Der hat jede Menge andere Probleme
Aber ich glaube Muskelprobleme hat er nicht
Der war früher
So Wettkampfmäßiger
Gewichtsheber und dann Ringer
Also wenn er eins hat
Sind es Muskeln
Aber ansonsten hat er ganz andere Probleme
Wann sollte man circa anfangen
Für die Abschlussprüfung zum Physi zu lernen
Hier haben bestimmt schon welche Empfang
Ja paar Wochen vorher
Also ich meine du musst jetzt nicht
Zwei Jahre vorher anfangen
Es reicht wenn du weißt wann deine Abschlussprüfung ist
Wenn du da
Irgendwie so mal anfängst
So sagen wir mal
Zwei Monate bevor die Prüfung ist
Fängst dir schon mal an Gedanken zu zu machen
Und suchst dir schon mal ein paar Prüfungen
Im Internet raus
Und so richtig interessant wird es eigentlich nur
So ein paar Wochen bevor die Prüfung ist
Weil du vergisst es ja auch wieder
Es hat keinen Sinn wenn du jetzt einfach
Zwei Monate vorher schon alle Prüfungen durchmachst
Und dann nix mehr und hast wieder vergessen
Du kannst zwei Monate vorher schon mal reingucken
Fang an dir Gedanken zu machen
Zwei Monate vor der Prüfung
So und so richtig Prüfungen machen
Würde ich natürlich so die zwei drei Wochen
Vorher richtig anfangen und alle Prüfungen durchmachen
Jeden Tag
Dass du jeden Tag mal so eine Abschlussprüfung dir anguckst
Und jeden zweiten Tag eine Abschlussprüfung anguckst
Dass du einfach in dieser Denkweise drin bist
Das ist das Schwierigste
Die Prüfungen an sich sind gar nicht schwer
Zu verstehen was die IHK wissen will
Ist eigentlich die Herausforderung
Mikrogeräte haben meistens eine gute Preisleistung
Ja genau
Den mein ich
Dazu muss es erstmal schneien
Da sieht es ja aktuell nicht aus
Ich könnte alternativ anbieten
Leute was haltet ihr davon
Nachdem das nächste Schneestelzvideo
Übrigens wer
Ich weiß dass immer noch Leute hier
Falsch ausgedrückt so mein ich es nicht
Ich weiß dass es immer mehr Leute hier gibt
Die Twitch tatsächlich den Channel
Über Twitch gefunden haben und nicht über Youtube
Es gibt so ein
Ungewolltes Meme Video von mir
Auf Youtube
Und zwar ich weiß nicht
Was mit dem Video passiert ist auf Youtube
Aber eigentlich ist das Video mega
Langweilig aber es hat 2 Millionen
Aufrufe
Ups falsch
Das Video hat 2 Millionen Aufrufe
Leute ich habe bis heute
Nicht die leiseste Ahnung warum
Dieses Video 2 Millionen Aufrufe hat
Zumindest es passiert in diesem Video nichts
Außer
Dass ich durch mein
So ein bisschen Schnee bedeckten
Garten laufe
Der noch nicht mal großartig
Schnee bedeckt ist
Der Teich ist zugefroren
Es gab schon
So ein paar kleine zweite Teile
Ab und zu mal
Wo Schnee gelegen hat
Hat nur keiner mitbekommen
Weil die Videos zu Recht eigentlich
Keine Sau interessieren
Du weißt wie mein Garten aussieht
Aber also nachdem es nicht schneit
Kann ich ein Schneestellvideo
Nicht bieten
Ich könnte aber
Ja ich weiß
Es sind einige aber ich verstehe immer noch nicht
Warum Youtube das promoten wollte
Aber ich könnte aber
Was ihr davon haltet
Ich könnte mal ein Video machen
Wie nimmt man sowas auf
Wir könnten mal 6km
Durch den Wald rennen zusammen
Und
Könnt ihr hören
Wie ich halb am verrecken bin
Je nachdem wie schnell ich renne
Wie nimmt man
Sowas mit ner GoPro
Wahrscheinlich
Twitch Livestream mach ich nicht
Da werde ich noch geleakt
Oder Kamera falsch
Wie viel wiegst du mittlerweile
Ja zwischen 91 und 93
Das schwankt
Je nachdem wann und wieviel ich anhab
Beim wiegen
Wenn ich nach dem Rennen
Gatsche Roll
Auf die Waage
Dann ist es eher 91, irgendwas
Und wenn ich
In Jeans und nach dem Essen
Dann ist es 93,8 oder so
Also ich bin guter Dinge
Dass ich es schaffe bis Ende des Jahres
Wenn ich weiter mache
Mit meinem alle 2 Tage Rennen
Auf unter 90
Und
Hat letztens im Chat einer geschrieben
Dass ich mir gar nicht so viele Gedanken mache
Ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt
Ich beschäftige mich ja immer relativ wenig
Letztens hat einer im Chat geschrieben
Max mach dir nicht so viele Gedanken
Wenn du am Anfang nicht so viel abnimmst
Dadurch dass du
Dadurch dass du jetzt erst
Seit einem Monat machst
Habe ich jetzt auch erst mal viele Muskeln dabei gekriegt
So in Beinen und Wade und alles
Sodass ich quasi weniger Fett habe
Und mehr Muskeln und deswegen sieht man es nicht so sehr
Auf der Waage
Wie groß bist du
Ich bin 1,74
Echt rennt der auch durch den Wald
Moin Christian
Und hast dein Rauchmelder gekauft
Du wunderst dich jetzt
Vielleicht woher weißt er das noch
Tja manche Sachen merke ich mir
Ihr könnt aber nicht erwarten dass ich das in 2 Tagen noch weiß
Manche Sachen
Habe ich so im Hinterkopf
Die sind aber eine Woche später wieder weg
Aber irgendwie manchmal ploppt sowas auf
Ja
So Leute lasst mal gucken
Können wir uns noch ein paar Videos angucken
Was haben wir denn hier noch schönes
Sunshine
Ah Maurice hat ein Video gemacht
Über Diablo 4 das wollte ich mir angucken
Chat gibt
Spielt noch jemand von euch Diablo 4
Ich hab den Release komplett verdrängt
Und hab nie damit angefangen
Habs mir nie gekauft obwohl das immer hieß
Eigentlich ein richtig gutes Game wieder geworden
Aber in den letzten paar Wochen
Gerade auch mit der
Neuen Season
Ist es enorm still
Um Diablo 4 geworden
Wie siehts bei euch aus spielt noch irgendjemand von euch
Also
Ich hab nicht vor es mir noch zu kaufen
Wo ich viel mehr Bock
Drauf habe ist wenn irgendwann mal
Exile 2 rauskommt
Diablo 4 ist dead
Gucken wir uns vielleicht doch mal das Video von
Maurice an
Was er so zum Besten zu geben hat
Ich spiele
Im Durchschnitt 2 Stunden pro Woche
Ganz ehrlich das könnte ich nicht
Wenn ich so ein Game spiele wie Diablo
Oder generell so ein grind heavy Game
Dann muss ich entweder krass ein Kreislauf
Grind machen für ein paar Wochen
Und dann wieder warten bis die nächste Season kommt
Oder ich spiele es erst gar nicht
Titan Quest 2
Wirklich
Wurde das angekündigt
Das habe ich überhaupt
Nicht mitbekommen
Ja Titan Quest war mega nice
Das würde ich tatsächlich
Das würde ich tatsächlich feiern
Wenn es Titan Quest 2 gebe
Das Original ist so alt das kennt wahrscheinlich kaum noch einer
Super Nintendo Spiele
Da gibt es
Da gibt es ja auch glücklicherweise sehr viele
Was ist ein guter Startgehalt
Es kommt immer ganz drauf an
Region
Branche
Was sind deine Spezialitäten
Kann man immer schlecht sagen
Ich sag immer
Auf die Frage
Auf die Frage hin
Sag ich immer das was ich verdient habe
Und was es jetzt hochgerechnet wäre
Also mein Einstiegsgehalt
Ich bin zwar nicht Anwendungsentwickler
Aber das einzige was ich euch sagen kann
Mein Einstiegsgehalt damals war
20.600
Das sind glaube ich hochgerechnet heute
Irgendwie 45k
So in dem Dreh
Aber hier haben wir noch ein paar Spiegel
So einen komischen Rechner, Inflationsrechner
Ja
33.500
33.600
Genau das waren mal 45k
Also würde ich sagen ist ein ganz gutes Einstiegsgehalt
45k
Ich kann es dir aber nicht wirklich sagen
Weil
Die aktuellen Vergleichswerte fehlen
Sagt mir nix
Lasst uns nochmal gucken
Wir gucken uns ein bisschen was noch an
Entweder wir können uns ein Video von Morissa angucken
Zu Diablo 4
Oh was ist das
Putting together my own retro gaming
Oh da hab ich Bock drauf Leute
Boomer, Boomer guckt Boomer-Technik
Ich stehe auf solche Videos
Es ist unglaublich unsinnig
Niemand
Hand aufs Herz
Wie der Kabum gesagt hätte
Aber
Es ist eigentlich total unsinnig
Sowas zu bauen
Weil du kannst
Quasi alles interessante
In irgendeiner Art und Weise heute immer noch
Auf Rechnern spielen
Okay vielleicht
War das ein bisschen zu viel des Guten
Es gibt jetzt Leute die sagen nein Max aber mein Lieblingsspiel
Von 1997
Das ist komplett
Unplayable
Ich kann prinzipiell alle ganz alten Spiele spielen
Mit sowas wie DOSBOX zum Beispiel
So
Die richtig großen Games von damals
Die funktionieren heute
Sogar Siedler 2
Läuft mit nem
Mit nem Mod
Ich glaub sogar ohne Mod
Heute noch aufm aktuellen PC
Also
Ich sehe das sehr
Nischenmäßig
Das einzige wofür ich es wirklich sinnvoll halte
Retro Experience haben will
Und dazu zählt für mich auch
Sowas wie
EAX Sound
Und Voodoo Graphics
Wenn man mit wie hieß das Ding
Wie hieß das DirectX von Voodoo
Glide 3D
Oder sowas spielen will
Okay das lasse ich mir gefallen
Also wenn man wirklich das so
1 zu 1 100%ig haben wollte
Wie man das keine Ahnung
1998 gespielt hat
Okay dann dann lasse ich mir das gefallen
Aber ich gucke mir trotzdem
Unglaublich gerne solche Videos an
Weil mich das immer an
So die beste PC Zeit erinnert
Für mich
Deswegen gucken wir das jetzt auch einfach
Ich hoffe das taugt
Ich kenn den Channel nicht
Und
PC's over the years
Some have been fairly normal
While some
Ist das etwa
Windows ME im Hintergrund
Sehe ich das richtig
Das ist das ist
Das ist Windows ME oder
Mit diesen Icons
Have not
Und das war damals
Der letzte Schrei diese ergonomischen Tastaturen
Die fanden damals alle geil
Mittlerweile ist das nicht mehr so angesagt
Aber das ist das was ich meine
Du kannst alle diese Spiele heute auch
Auf modernen Rechner spielen
Wobei ich mir beim ersten Stronghold
Nicht so sicher bin
Ob das zumindest die Version die es damals
Noch auf CD's gab
Läuft
Aber Baldur's Gate 1 und 2
Kannst du definitiv spielen
Auch die Original Fassung
Auf neuen PC's
Sei es mit irgendeinem Fanpatch oder so
Und die Enhanced Edition
Auf jeden Fall
Da kenn ich auch einen der so eine Maus hat
So eine
Hochkant Maus
Warcraft 2 war mega
Also ich muss sagen
Warcraft ist für mich
Eindeutig das 3er
Ich habe Warcraft nie großartig
Competitive Multiplayer gespielt
Aber die Warcraft 3 Kampagne
Ist finde ich
Bis heute eigentlich
Immer noch
Eines der besten
Die je gemacht wurden
Ja
Gibt so ein paar Sachen
Das fällt einem immer so aus dem Stehgreif
Nicht direkt ein
Aber wenn man dann eine Weile drüber nachdenkt
Sei es jetzt Filme
Spiele
Meinetwegen auch Bücher
Falls jemand Bücher liest
Ich habe in meinem Leben
Nicht viele Bücher gelesen
Fiction Bücher
Sachbücher
Und so habe ich jede Menge gelesen
Aber wirklich Story
Bücher und so habe ich nicht
Ich habe auch
Niemals Harry Potter gelesen
Hat mich nie interessiert
Interessiert mich heute auch nicht
Ich habe noch nicht mal Herr der Ringe gelesen
Weil ich es übelst langatmig fand
Es gibt verdammt wenig Bücher
Die ich wirklich gelesen habe
Ich zähle
Ich war hörbuchmäßig dabei
Nicht viel
Ich habe mir früher
Jede Gamestar gekauft
Generals war auch mega
Eines der besten Storys die ich je
Gelesen ist das falsche Wort
Konsumiert habe
Max ich habe wirklich
Angst drauf zu gehen
Bevor die Technik so ist
Ich glaube die werden wir alle nicht erleben
Nicht in der Form wie man sich das jetzt
Science Fiction mäßig vielleicht vorstellt
Eines der besten und lustigsten
Und wie soll man sagen
Also herausstechendsten
Buchstorys die ich kenne
Die ich je
Mir zur Gemüte geführt habe
Ist wie hieß das
Das ist uralt
Ich weiß gar nicht ob das noch jemand kennt von euch
Die Farben der Magie
Genau
Das da
Das ist der erste Scheibenwelt Roman
Kennt das jemand von euch
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Ich glaube das ist das einzige
Was ich kenne aus der ganzen Serie
Und das ist glaube ich
Auch das erste
Aus der Serie
Das ist wirklich sehr unik
Es ist teilweise schon echt bescheuert
Womit ich so denke
Aber
Ich glaube das ist was Buchstorys angeht
Eines der einprägsamsten gewesen
Bücher und
Buchstorys gibt es echt nicht viel
Hab ich geguckt
Ich hab Season 1 geguckt
Fand ich Season 1 relativ gut
Ich hab Season 2 angefangen und dachte mir
Übelst lahmarschig
Aber dann ist mir gedämmert woran das liegt
Die waren ja schon durch mit der Buchvorlage
In Season 1
Die mussten sich irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen
Für Season 2
Und das ist halt aufgefallen
Ich hab dann gar nicht weiter geguckt
Ich hab nur die ersten 2-3 Folgen geguckt
In Season 2 hatte ich keinen Bock mehr
Aber Season 1 war echt gut
Gamester habe ich mir damals jede gekauft
So lass mal gucken
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben
Ich wollte mir das Retro PC Video anschauen
Ansonsten überlege ich gerade
Was gibt es
Fällt mir gar nicht so viel ein
Ich hab mir Herr der Ringe als
Hörvariante gegeben
Ähm
Die Zwerge habe ich gelesen
Tatsächlich als Buch
Kennt das jemand
Das ist auch so Fantasy Kram
Ähm
Ansonsten was habe ich
Ich hab echt keine Ahnung
Es ist wenig es ist wirklich wenig
Was ich gelesen habe an Büchern
Ich hab das Witcher
Die Witcher Short Stories
Hab ich
Mir vorlesen lassen
Also das allererste Witcher Buch
Was nur Kurzgeschichten waren
Das hab ich mir gekauft
Bei Audible
Aber ansonsten
Ich bin kein großer Bücherleser
So aber jetzt gucken wir echt mal in das Video
Sonst wird da nie was
None of those desktops have been mine to keep
This time let's change that
Oh guck dir mal da
Sehe ich da unten richtig
Ein Zipdrive
Jomega
100 MB
Chat erinnert sich da noch jemand dran
Waren das 100 MB
Es waren 100 MB
Zipdrive
Sowas wollte ich immer haben hatte ich nie
Ich glaube die konnten so viel speichern
Was waren da innen drin
War da in so nem Zip
War da Bänder drin in so nem Zipdrive
Zipdrive
Äh ja
Teardown
Waren da Bänder drin oder wie hat das funktioniert
Ne da waren
Irgendwelche Magnetplatten
Oder so drin
Äh das ist was anderes
Nun gut
Zipdrives wollte ich immer haben hatte ich nie
Es gab da noch so ne andere
Technik die nannte sich
O-Drive
Oder sowas
O-Drive das hatte 120 MB
Ey wie sowas
120 MB
Ist das O-Drive
Hm
Ne
Ey das ist irgendwas anderes gewesen
Egal schaut mal her
Oh guck mal da eine
Ist das
Ne ist nicht
Ok lasst mal gucken was baut das sich denn zusammen
Wupp wupp wupp
Wupp wupp
Erstmal auf dem Mainboard rumfräsen
Wunderbar
Zipdrives waren doch wie Floppys
Ne die waren nicht Kompat
Also die waren ein bisschen dicker
Ne
Neisses
richtig schönes
Oldschool
Das hatte
damals übrigens jeder Monitor
überall war so ein
Energystar
draufgeklebt
ist, dann stand auch irgendwas von Energy Star. Das war so ein Ding, das, das war so, das haben
damals die Hersteller gedacht, die Leute geben da was drauf, wenn das, wenn die da, wenn da der
Energy Star ist. Hat ja für den Klimawandel nicht so viel gebracht, der Energy Star.
Man muss aber auch sagen, dass zur damaligen Zeit,
war es bei Gehäusen echt schon so, dass eigentlich je größer, je cooler war man. Das war die Zeit,
wo man einen Big Tower hatte, ohne dass es wirklich Sinn gemacht hat, einen Big Tower zu
haben. Man hat dann natürlich damals noch ein bisschen mehr eingebaut im Rechner, weil es noch
viel weniger Onboard gab. Also ihr müsst euch vorstellen, damals hatte kein Mainboard eine
Netzwerkkarte Onboard. Die hatten, die hatten auch, du hattest damals, du hast damals eh mehr
eingebaut. Du hast eine Netzwerkkarte eingebaut, du hast noch ein Modem eingebaut, du hast eine
Soundkarte eingebaut. Viele Mainboards hatten dann nicht mal Onboard Sound. Zusätzliche Extensions,
alles, alles mögliche. Eine Fritz-Karte zum Beispiel wurde damals oft noch eingebaut. Und
du hattest durchaus damals im Rechner vier, fünf Add-On-Karten stecken, plus eine Grafikkarte,
wohingegen heute eigentlich außer einer Grafikkarte und vielleicht noch einer
Capture-Karte, vielleicht eine Capture-Karte, eigentlich nichts mehr drin steckt. Was habt
ihr sonst großartig im Rechner noch stecken? Manch eine 10G-Netzwerkkarte vielleicht noch,
wenn ihm das 2,5 von Mainboard nicht reicht. 2D-Grafikkarte, 3D ja, in Zeiten von Voodoo-Grafik
hattest du natürlich auch noch eins oder zwei Voodoo-2-Karten drinnen, plus noch eine normale
Grafikkarte, dass du dein Windows-Desktop sehen konntest, natürlich, ja klar. Das musste dann
mit so einem Passthrough-Kabel durchgeschliffen werden, was die Bildqualität auch nicht gerade
besser gemacht hat. Alles VGA. So.
Also, wie man sich vorstellen kann, war ich ziemlich begeistert,
einen neuen zu finden. Es gibt vier, fünfeinhalb und zwei dreieinhalb
Inch-Bays auf der Vorderseite, aber was diesen Fall bemerkenswert macht, ist diese Translucent-Teal-Swoosh-Form.
Ich dachte immer, diese Design-Aesthetik wäre viel Spaß, weil sie eine viel interessanter Zeit
in Computern und Konsumenten-Elektronik bezeichnet. Sie kam mit einem Standard-ATX-IO-Schild,
der bereits installiert wurde, zusammen mit...
Übrigens, PC-Gehäuse, zur damaligen Zeit haben ja noch total viele Leute geraucht,
damals waren halt PC-Gehäuse richtig schnell gelb, also in vielen Wohnungen.
Es war übrigens vollkommen normal, dass Gehäuse damals schwer zu öffnen waren und teilweise gar
nicht richtig entgradet, wenn ihr nicht aufgepasst habt. Und diese ganzen Komfort-Sachen von Verschlüsse
zum Auf- und Zumachen, zum Klipsen anstatt zum Schrauben und so, ordentliche Schrauben,
die man nur mit der Hand... gab es alles nicht.
Also ich hab mich nie so sehr geschnitten an einem Gehäuse, dass ich jetzt irgendwelche Narben hätte.
Also eine Sache, die ich mal geschafft hab, die ist aber noch gar nicht so lange her und die hat
auch mit dem Gehäuse nichts zu tun. Ich hab's mal geschafft, mir einen Pin-Header in die Ferse
zu stecken. Aus Versehen. Das tut weh. Also nicht den kompletten Header, nur so ein Ding. Aber da hat
man wieder gemerkt, dass Schmerzempfinden und Berührungsempfinden entkoppelt sind. Zumindest
im Fuß so ein bisschen. Denn ich hab es gespürt, dass ich mir das gerade in die Ferse gestochen
habe, aber es hat erst eine Sekunde später wehgetan. Ich hab das noch gemerkt, das lag irgendwo hier
unterm Schreibtisch. Irgendwo hier unterm Schreibtisch. Irgendwie runtergefallen, war irgendwas
gebasteltes, ausgepackt, keine Ahnung, runtergefallen. Und ich weiß es noch, ich hatte
keine Socken an und ich wollte mich am Boden mit meinem Stuhl ein bisschen nach vorne ziehen. Der
Stuhl war ein bisschen weit hinten, ich wollte mich nach vorne ziehen mit dem Fuß über den Boden. Und
dann bin ich halt mit der Ferse über den Teppich und hab gemacht so, zack, nach vorne, also nach
vorne gezogen, dass der Stuhl nach vorne geht. Und auf einmal spüre ich und höre ich es bei mir an
der Ferse. Also ich hab es gehört, meine Ferse hat mir ein bisschen dicke gehauen. An der Ferse
habe ich auf einmal gehört, hat so richtig, so als würde gerade, wie wenn dir irgendwie ein bisschen
was dickeres so durch Papier durchstecht. Es hat so einen richtigen Durchstech-Sound. Und ich hab
es auch gespürt, aber es hat nicht wehgetan. Aber nach 1-2 Sekunden habe ich dann gemerkt, au, mein
Bein, mein Fuß. Man hat so ein bisschen Spike bei der Ferse, man hat so ein bisschen Spike, au. Na gut,
ich meine, ich hab es dann rausgezogen und so, alles gut, ist jetzt nicht keine wahnsinnig schlimme
Verletzung draus entstanden. Ich hatte bloß ein paar Tage wirklich Probleme beim Auftreten danach.
Also ein Ding, so ein Ding geht schon, wie lange wird denn das sein? Ein Zentimeter oder so? 34
Jahre her. Also was ich da habe ist, ich hab, also da habe ich nichts. Ich hab, ähm, lasst mal gucken,
welche Seite ist es das? Rechtses Knie ist es hier. Rechtses, rechtes Knie und ich glaube außen hier am
linken. Zumindest am rechten Knie sieht man das heute noch. Da bin ich mal übelst mit dem Fahrrad,
als ich klein war. Da war ich, keine Ahnung, 8 oder so, richtig lang her. Bin ich übelst mit dem
Fahrrad aufs Maul gefallen. Auf nem, auf nem, auf nem Steinweg, der auch noch so richtig raues
Pflaster hatte. Da bin ich übelst aufs Maul gefallen, aufs Knie und das hat auch geblutet
als Fuck und ich kann mich da heute noch dran erinnern. Ich hatte da gefühlt wochenlang irgendwie
so, so, so, so, so, ja, wie das halt aussieht, wenn das halt wieder zuwächst, ja und so, so, so, so,
so, so, so, so, wie heißt denn das so, so braun halt ist, wenn das so zuwächst und das sieht man
heute noch. Also man sieht, dass an der Stelle mal ziemlich, ziemlich große Verletzung war. So,
aber lange genug erzählt. Schorf heißt das, genau, aber lange, lange, lange genug über
irgendwelche Verletzungen. Ich wollte mir eigentlich das Video angucken. Oh ja, oh, nice, nice.
Kaltgeräte Kabel, übrigens so auch so ein Ding, was sich ja 20 Jahren nicht geändert hat,
ne, diese, diese 0815 Kaltgeräte Stecker. Oh, guck mal hier, das ist der dicke, der dicke PS2
Vorgänger. Ne, PS2? Ist das PS, ja es hieß PS2, oder? Das war diese DIN Stecker für Tastaturen
damals noch. DIR hab ich noch nie gehört. Kennt, kennt jemand DIR als Hersteller? Erstmal,
erstmal das richtig gute, 15 Jahre alte LC Power rein. Okay, ja die sind ganz brauchbar,
denke ich. Warum nicht das gute China-Chinesen LC Power Netzteil?
OMG! Guck dir mal, guck dir mal, wie klein der ATX Stecker damals noch gewesen ist. Heute,
heute ist der ATX Stecker gefühlt doppelt so lang. Ne, ist er nicht. Ich glaube,
der ATX Stecker heute hat auch nur noch einen Vierer mehr, aber damals war der richtig mini.
Ah. Windows XP? Okay, also da fällt mir jetzt wirklich nicht viel ein,
was exklusiv auf Windows XP läuft und später nicht mehr. Windows 98 und ME und sowas hätte
ich ja verstanden, aber okay. Übrigens, wir wissen gleich, wir sind im Kona Land 115.
Windows, but not all of them will and of course tinkering with period correct hardware is part
of the retro charm. And here's what will be powering this system. A motherboard from Intel
Model D 845. Guter. Das ist auch AGP, oder? Ja, das ist auch AGP, das ist auch kein PC Express.
GEBV2. That's a bit of alphabet soup, but it's a solid ATX board that was introduced in late 2002.
6 PCI Slots plus AGP. Ein PC von 2002? Das geht für mich schon fast nicht mehr als retro durch.
P2 RAM Slots. Ja, bester, bester AGP Stecker. Er hatte damals, er hatte damals schon dieses
komische zum Einhaken. Kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern. Ich hätte, ich habe gedacht,
das haben sie erst mit PCI Express erfunden, dieses zum Einhaken.
Board audio, video and networking and USB 2.0 all make this a competent mainstream motherboard
during its time. IDE Anschlüsse. Perhaps not the most exciting thing on the market. As the tape
indicates, it came with a 2.4 gigahertz processor and one gigabyte of RAM. A perfect fit for Windows
XP. Also für die Zeit, also ist es auf jeden Fall eines der deutlich schnelleren Windows XP System.
Before I got too much farther into assembly, the heatsink simply unclipped from the CPU socket
and sure enough, it looked like this was still the original paste. Cleaning it off confirmed
what I suspected. This is a socket 478 Pentium 4. These were solid CPUs. Das ist schon fast kein
Retro mehr. Da könnte man ja, da könnte man ja fast Windows 7 noch drauf installieren. Oder was
heißt fast? Man könnte da sogar wahrscheinlich ohne Probleme Windows 7 drauf installieren.
Allerdings ist der Pentium 4 vermutlich kein Dual-Core, sondern ein Single-Core. Also das
wäre schon hardcore lahm. Ich glaube es gab Pentium 4s mit Dual-Core. Das war das aller
allererste Dual-Core was die hatten. Ich glaube die sind Pentium 4D oder sowas.
Ja sowas in der Richtung gab es glaube ich. Warum ist da ein Loch? Wo? Wo ist ein Loch?
Schettke? Da! Eine exzellente Frage. Warum ist da ein Loch? Kann das sein, dass das gar kein
Loch ist, sondern einfach nur von einem Tropfen vom Reinigungsmittel? Ne das hat ein Loch. Warum
hat die CPU ein Loch? Hatten die damals alle ein Loch? Weil da ist ja offensichtlich nichts
drunter. Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Guckt mal mit wie kleinen Furzlüfter man
damals ausgekommen ist. Und beim Pentium 4 haben sie, also beim Pentium 4 haben sie ja festgestellt,
dass ihre, ihre Roadmap nicht mehr funktioniert. Dass der Scheiß einfach zu heiß wird mit höheren
Taktraten. Pentium 4 war so das Ende der Fahnenstange für Single-Core-CPUs. Klar es
hat sich auch vieles verbessert. Die Single-Core-Performance ist heute trotzdem deutlich
besser als bei einem Pentium 4. Aber die Taktraten haben sich nicht so extrem mehr verbessert,
vielleicht auch knapp verdoppelt. Wenn die Boost anhaben 4,8. Aber ansonsten merkst du halt den
CPUs heute an, dass da deutlich mehr drauf ist. Mit so einem kleinen Popel-Lüfter kannst du da
heute nicht mal da anstinken gegen die, gegen die Abwärme. Ich meine das ist mein erster Rechner
mit, mit Wasserkühlung den ich hier habe. Weil das Ding eben richtig reinhaut.
Oh, guck mal da hat schon, da hat schon Sound und Netzwerk on board. Ja klar,
ich meine Windows XP 2002, da war das auch schon so. Aber davor war das nicht so. Es ist
auch gar nicht so lang gewesen, dass es dort, dass es Standard war. Onboard-Audio und Onboard-Sound.
Also 4 Jahre davor wäre das schon, wäre, hätte das anders ausgesehen. Ich meine 4 Jahre davor
haben die Leute auch teilweise noch BNC-Netzwerkkarten gehabt, mit einem Terminator und einem BNC-Kabel
und einem T-Stück und sowas.
Ja, das stimmt. Erstmal das Ding reingeprügelt.
Das war aber damals schon eines der besseren Gehäuse, wenn das so umfangreich war,
was damit geliefert wurde. Also ich hatte damals auch richtig billige Gehäuse, da musstest du
Schrauben dir von anderen Geräten raussuchen, um da ordentlich was einzubauen. Und, und diese
Abstandshalter fürs Mainboard. Ich war damals viel zu blöd, ich wusste gar nicht, dass man die
benutzen muss. Glücklicherweise hatten die meisten Gehäuse schon welche drin. Und wie, Abstandshalter,
wer braucht denn sowas? Einfach Mainboard ins Gehäuse reinklatschen und gut ist?
Ja, alte Gehäuse, ich vermisse sie in der Anwendung nicht. Okay, ich muss sagen, ich finde die Optik
heute von PCs deutlich gefälliger als damals. Aber ich gucke mir alte Gehäuse und alte Rechner
trotzdem gerne an, weil es mich eben an die Zeit erinnert, wo das Zeug angesagt war. Nicht,
dass ich es heute noch haben möchte. Richtig Boomer-Modus aktiviert, ja klar. Aber es ist ein
ganz gutes Board, ich meine, das hat ein AGP, ein Onboard-Sound, ein Onboard-Netzwerk und sechs
PCI-Steckplätze. Also das ist schon eines für die damalige Zeit, echt eines der besseren Boards
gewesen. Da hat er aber Glück gehabt. Ich meine, damit haben die Hersteller heute noch Probleme,
dass du diesen Müll anschließen kannst. Das ist ja schon mal was. Und ich meine,
ich war damals schon froh, wenn die Markierung drauf war, wo der Anfang ist. Ja, hatte ich auch
keine Ahnung. Wie klein, wie klein der ATX-Stecker damals einfach war.
Mini-ATX-Stecker. Oh, der gute PC-Speaker. Ja, sowas haben die Gehäuse heute auch nicht mehr. Ist
auch ganz gut so. Aber einen Onboard-Peeper haben die meisten Mainboards noch. Das stimmt,
das stimmt. Und vom Preis her, vom Preis her auch. Du konntest dir damals drei richtig gute
PCs bauen für den Preis von einem oder von einer 40,90 oder so. Na, für den Preis von einem PC.
Also wenn du damals 2000 oder damals hast du für 1000 Mark schon ordentlich einen PC gekriegt und
2000 war wirklich exzellenter PC. Ich rede noch von vor 2000, ja. Damals haben High-End-Grafikkarten
250 Mark gekostet. Zum Beispiel die TNT-1-Karten, die es damals gab und sowas. Also, Voodoo-SLI war
natürlich damals auch schon teurer, aber bei weitem nicht so krass wie heute ein 40,90 oder sowas.
Das stimmt, damals brauchte man alle zwei Jahre eine neue CPU, GPU. Die war nach eineinhalb Jahren
eigentlich hoffnungslos veraltet. Damals ging es aber auch rasend schnell, die Entwicklung.
Ich meine, muss ich das mal überlegen. Wir sind dort in ein paar Jahren von sowas wie Doom zu
sowas wie Far Cry gegangen. Also guck mal, Far Cry 1 Release Date war 2000, 2004 und Doom war glaube
ich 1994. Also in diesen zehn Jahren sind wir quasi von sowas hier, wir sind von Doom Graphics,
das ist nicht Doom 1 Graphics, wir sind von sowas hier, wir sind innerhalb von zehn Jahren von sowas
hier zu sowas hier gegangen. Und das ist noch nicht mal, guckt euch das mal an, das war mega
für die damalige Zeit, Far Cry 1. Jetzt mal ernsthaft, das sind Welten einfach dazwischen.
Far Cry 1 geht heute noch halbwegs durch, als man kann sich es durchaus angucken und für viele Leute,
die nicht so sehr auf Retro und Pixel stehen, die würden in Doom heute im Leben die Handschuhe
anziehen. Noch mal zehn Jahre und dann hast du BF3. Ja, das ist richtig, aber ich finde der Sprung von
Doom Graphics zu Far Cry Graphics war natürlich schon... und natürlich in der Zwischenzeit kamen
ganz viele Zwischenstationen noch, aber in den zehn Jahren ist so extrem viel passiert. Ich glaube,
1993 bis 2003 oder sagen wir 1994 bis... ich weiß gar nicht genau, wann Doom 1 Release war. 1994,
ich glaube 1993. In diesen zehn Jahren von Doom bis Far Cry 1, es hat sich davor 3D Graphics nicht
so schnell entwickelt, davor gab es ja kaum wirklich 3D Graphics und Doom war ja auch noch
nicht so richtig alles komplett 3D Graphics und das wird sich auch nie wieder so schnell und in
den Detailgrad ändern. Ja, Grafik nicht so sehr. Es war gut, CoD 4 war Grafik durchaus nice,
hat aber auch eher in anderen Bereichen Maßstäbe gesetzt, aber Far Cry 1 war für die
damalige Zeit einfach das optisch beste Game, was man sich vorstellen konnte. Also in den Jahren
hat sich wirklich enorm viel getan. Ich habe vergessen, wo wir stehen geblieben sind, ja.
This case lacks a spot for a rear fan, so I wanted to at least install a front one. This
plastic cage can be unclipped to reveal the air inlet. I picked up a basic 80mm Noctua
3-pin fan. I wasn't too worried. Immer mehr Lüfter Luft reinziehen lassen ins Gehäuse,
als rauspusten lassen. About noise, since it's likely the rest of this machine will end up
making a racket anyway. The cage not only serves as support for any long expansion cards. Ey,
es ist glücklicherweise kein hässlicher brauner Noctua. To snap the fan directly into it. It doesn't
look like it'll impede air flow much either, but the inlet in the case itself is a different matter.
I'm not sure who thought. Guckt euch das mal an. Kann man sicherlich richtig gut Luft durch anziehen,
oder? Durch die paar Schlitze. This was okay, but I needed to do something about it.
Damals, damals kam auch keiner noch auf die Idee, so nach dem Motto, wie wärs mal mit nem,
mit nem Luftfilter oder sowas. Staubfilter, pff, brauchen wir nicht.
Metrohackery was in order. I unclipped the front bezel, then simply chopped out the fan grill
with an old pair of cutters. It doesn't matter if the results are ugly, since you'd never see
this with the fan in place and the bezel on. Und jetzt, und jetzt reingreifen ins Gehäuse
und bisschen rumtasten und sich den Finger aufschneiden. This ought to help with air flow
quite a bit. The fan snapped into the cage, then the cage snapped into the case.
Nicht nur Airflow, Chat, nicht nur Airflow hat damals niemand interessiert,
Lautstärke hat damals auch so keinen interessiert. Keines dieser Mainboards hatte irgendwie ne
Lüfterregelung oder sowas. Du hast es angemacht, der Lüfter hat geblasen und er
bläst die ganze Zeit durch. Und nachdem das so kleine Lüfter waren, waren die oftmals auch
relativ hochfrequente. Die ganze Zeit. Und damals waren Leute noch so pp-ger und haben
den Rechner auch noch auf den Schreibtisch gestellt, dass du schön den Lüftersound im
Ohr hattest. But then I wanted to do some basic tests just to make sure things were working
before I got any further. The machine powered on like it should, but there was a pretty
ominous sound. Festplatten-Spin-up war eh immer noch das Beste.
Und dann, und dann, was haben Festplatten dann gemacht? Wer kennt's noch? Nach dem Anlauf-Sound,
was hat's dann gemacht in der Festplatte? Das lief an und dann hat's gemacht,
klack, genau, klack, grrrr. Ja, klack hat's gemacht, weil der Lesekopf rausgeschwenkt ist
und warum es grrrr gemacht hat, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Message waiting for me. Shutdown due to overheating. I hope that was just a false
alarm due to the dead clock battery it was also complaining about. Das war damals auch in den
tollen, ja? No keyboard found. Press any key to continue. I got the coin cell replaced with a
new one and that seemed to help. These Intel boards were solid but kind of boring. There's
no option for overclocking, for example, or making other- Ich mochte dieses, dieses BIOS,
diesen BIOS-Style. Heute hast du ja sogar Firmware-Update-Möglichkeiten im BIOS- und
Maus-Support. Nicht, dass ich was dagegen habe, aber ich mochte diesen BIOS-Style hier.
Oh, wie lange ich keinen CD-Brenner mehr im Rechner habe. Ich glaube, meine letzten drei
Rechner, also sprich, das ist dann, also sagen wir mal seit zehn Jahren oder so, hatte kein
Rechner von- Nee, länger, länger, länger. Chat, wann war euer letzter Rechner mit einem
CD-Laufwerk beziehungsweise einem Brenner? Irgendwo hab ich das Ding noch. Irgendwo hab
ich noch meinen CD oder DVD-Brenner, ich weiß es gar nicht. Irgendwo hab ich so einen Brenner
noch rumfliegen in irgendeiner Schublade. 2010, ja, so dürfte es bei mir auch gewesen sein in
dem Dreh. CD-Brenner ist immer noch drin. Okay, benutzt du den oder ist er einfach nur da?
Habe ich noch nie gehört. Ich meine, zum Thema selber brennen, kennt noch jemand die
Zeiten, wo du deinen Rechner nicht benutzen durftest, weil es dann zu wenig Daten gab,
um auf die CD zu schreiben und der Rolling kaputt war? Kann sich noch jemand an diesen
Shit erinnern? Also, das erscheint euch jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen, bisschen merkwürdig,
aber das war damals so. Wenn du ein, also, wenn du ein Laufwerk hattest, dass keine Buffer,
nee nicht Buffer, Underrun oder sowas, ja irgendwie sowas, Buffer Underrun Protection
hatte, also was quasi den, den, den Brennvorgang anhalten konnte, dann war der Rolling im Arsch,
wenn der Brennvorgang nicht am Stück passieren konnte.
... Read, pretty compelling speeds for the Era... Some other removable media I wanted support
for were floppies and Zip Disks... Und dann der Chipdrive. ... The hard drive was a tougher
decision. My first option was a 40 GB model from Samsung. While that company is best known for
its flash storage today, it also produced mechanical hard drives for a number of years and...
und macht es macht samsung keine festplatten mehr
ich habe glaube ich doch irgendwo eine samsung festplatte rumliegen
und übrigens hier
leute jumper pin settings
das ist was das vermisse ich ja aus dieser zeit wirklich nicht
pin settings
es gab mal was was konntest du bei pin settings machen
konntest master slave pin settings machen also es darf man heute nicht mehr
sagen aber damals hieß das so
master slave pin settings und cable select gab es dann noch
wo ich mir sehr unsicher bin was cable select eigentlich gemacht hat
und dann musstest du damals gucken
dass wenn du
deine festplatte und dein brenner
am gleichen ide kabel angeschlossen hast
dann musstest du gucken in welcher reihenfolge
du die jumperst
weil
sonst hast du probleme gekriegt teilweise dass dein brenner zu wenig daten
bekommen hat und das dann den rolling kaputt gemacht hat
wenn du maximum performst das war echt eine wissenschaft für sich das
anzuschließen und zu jumpern
limit capacity dass sie sich nur als 32 gig meldet
weil es ältere rechner gab die hatten halt probleme mit
festplatten über 32 gig
ERQ pin für ISA Karten
da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern mein vater hatte damals eine fritz ISA
fritz fritz kart
fritzbox kart ISA
musstest du windows installieren dann musstest du aufmachen den rechner
den pinschalter umstöpseln
auf den
zugewiesenen interrupt
und interrupt wie nennt man das ID
das waren echt
frickel sachen
nee das jumpern vermisse ich auch wirklich nicht
ach seagate hat die gekauft
ich glaube IBM macht auch keine
keine festplatten mehr
übrigens so eine hatte ich auch jahrelang
die habe ich nie benutzt
die hatte ich nur
weil mir die irgendjemand mal geschenkt hatte
ich hatte so eine 10 MB IBM festplatte
das war ein riesen ding alter
und
ich fand es irgendwie cool das war so eine festplatte
wenn du die aus dem fenster geschmissen hast die hat jemand abbekommen der war
tot
diese 10 MB IBM festplatte die war auch dreimal so hoch wie jetzt heutige
festplatten
es war so schlimm, dass sie den Namen Death Star bekamen
und IBM musste einen Klassikerfolgsverhandlungsausschuss eröffnen
es war so ein großes Problem, dass IBM die Harddrive-Division von Hitachi verkaufte
diese Firma hat eine ziemliche Verrücktheit
aber in den kommenden Jahren konnte sie Dinge umdrehen
und eine Reputation für die Produktion sehr reliable Harddrives bauen
aber das bedeutet nicht, dass dies eine wäre
die letzte und vielleicht sicherste Wahl war diese 80 GB Modell von Western Digital
die machen ja auch schon gefühlt seit
den Indusauriern Festplatten
es war geschlossen in einer statischen Tasche, aber der Sticker zeigte, dass es
verarbeitet wurde, wahrscheinlich vom Verkaufer
es wäre wahrscheinlich nur gut gewesen, aber ich habe mich entschieden, dass ein Rollen
des Stahls wäre mehr interessant für dieses Build
und bin tatsächlich mit der Duskstar gegangen
im Grunde war es eine Proposition, die nicht zu verlieren
wenn der Drive funktioniert, großartig
wenn er nicht funktioniert, dann würde es IBMs Probleme unterstreichen
und es für ein Mehr machen
wie hießen die anderen mit dieser Grafikkarte, die
schon richtig gut Texturen komprimieren konnte? Ich habe es vergessen
dann hattest du
Matrox noch
wie hieß denn... ne, Voodoo ist in die 3dfx
wie hießen diese Grafikkarte, die
irgendwie Savage 3D oder sowas
gab es sowas mal?
ja genau, von S3
das meine ich, ja VIA gab es auch noch
die waren mal so ein Jahr lang
der übelste Geheimtipp, weil
die waren günstig
und die hatten so eine
die hatten so eine richtig advanced
Textur-Compression
was sie zeitweise mega
preis-leistungsmäßig attraktiv gemacht hat
also für ein halbes Jahr
ihr wisst, ein halbes Jahr sind heute fünf Jahre, also
ein halbes Jahr zwischen 1993 und 2003
ist so viel wie heute fünf Jahre
was man austauschen muss im Rechner
ich weiß noch, es gab damals für Serious Sam 1, wann kam das raus?
auch schon ewig her
2001, ja
es gab damals für Serious Sam 1
gab es
für
ein extra Patch
nur für diese Grafikkarten
und da konnte man dann, weil die so eine nice Textur-Kompression hatten
ja genau
konnte man dann
an die Wand ranlaufen und der hat dann quasi noch mal
Details nachgeladen
für die Wand, das ist zum ersten Mal, dass man in einem Game an eine Wand
ranlaufen konnte
und dann von nahem auch Details in dieser Textur hatte
war richtig nice
nächste Generation hatten das natürlich alle andere auch
ja gut, Intel hat seit jeher Grafikkarten gemacht, aber die
haben gaming-technisch noch niemand jemals interessiert
ah
damals war übrigens normal, dass man sich einfach geschnitten hat, bei allem was man
so im Gehäuse macht
wenn man nicht aufgepasst hat
ah, ja, ok
das war aber damals eigentlich fast schon normal, dass so eine Front von so einem
Gehäuse recht
recht bunt bestückt war, mit allen möglichen Farben
nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, man wie, das kenne ich nicht mal, aber Phobis
Alter Leute, Phobis ist der größte Scheißland, ich fange jetzt nicht wieder mit meiner Phobis Story an
aber die haben mir schon erzählt, dass diese Person
dass diese Person
ein so ein
eine kleine
ein so
kleine
Aber die haben bei mir verschissen, aber zum Glück gibt es Phobias auch nicht mehr.
Nee, die kenne ich nicht.
Early 2000s, people were starting to pay attention to cable management.
So rounded IDE and floppy cables were a popular option among enthusiasts.
Das war aber schon richtiges High End Kabel hier.
They helped with airflow and overall kept things more tidy.
So they were definitely the way I wanted to go.
The optical drive got an audio lead.
Then I could hook up its own data cable.
Power connections were next.
And I used Velcro cable wrap to tie up the access.
Schöne Molex-Schlecker, die gibt es ja heute immer noch.
Nicely serviceable, but did emphasize that those expansion card slots.
Wisst ihr, was ich nicht verstanden habe?
Was der Vorteil ist von diesen komischen SATA-Stromschleckern versus die.
Warum man sich überhaupt dort was Neues ausgedacht hat.
Muss ja irgendeinen Sinn haben.
Ich meine, heutzutage hast du NVMe-SSDs, da ist es eh egal.
Ich stöpsel es dir in deinen M2-Slot rein.
Aber normale SATA-Sachen musst du immer noch anschließen
mit diesem komischen SATA-Stromkabel.
Ich weiß einfach nicht, was der Vorteil vom SATA-Stromkabel ist versus.
Die Molex bekommst du, wenn du Pech hast, nicht mehr raus.
Das stimmt schon.
Das Rein- und Rausstecken von diesen Molex-Dingern war schon nicht so geil.
Die haben sich ja öfters mal verbogen und verschoben und so.
Ja, du hast schon recht.
Tolle Stecker sind diese Molex-Dinger nicht gewesen.
Oh, Soundblaster live!
Ja, die lustigerweise an der Soundkarte dran war.
Ich habe nie verstanden, warum Soundkarten das gebraucht haben.
Guck mal, der hatte sogar schon einen digitalen Output.
Zwar noch kein TOS-Link,
aber diese andere Variante davon.
Einfach mal eine Grafikkarte mit einem Passiv-Kühler drauf.
Schon eine GeForce, ja. Das ist doch schon kein Retro-Rechner mehr.
Ja. Und, Chatge, kennt jemand noch dieses Ding?
Weiß jemand noch, was das für ein Anschluss ist?
Das braucht heute kein Mensch mehr, aber war damals ganz cool.
S-Video, richtig, ja.
Konnte man Fernseher anschließen.
Da gab es dann so komische Kabel,
die gingen von dort in so einen SCART-Stecker mit S-Video-Anschluss
und von dort dann an Fernseher.
Da konnte man den Fernseher anschließen am Rechner.
Halt eigentlich komplett unsinnig,
aber ich fand es damals mega nice,
dass man theoretisch einen Fernseher am Rechner anschließen konnte.
D-Sub ist der VGA-Stecker daneben.
TV-Karten. Ja, klar, TV-Karten hast du.
Also, man hatte generell damals, wenn man Multimedia-Zeug machen wollte,
also jetzt nicht bei der Rechner-Generation, aber davor,
ohne TV-Karte hättest du gar nicht auf die Idee kommen müssen,
irgendwelche Videos abzuspielen.
Weil, also gerade die Rechner-Generation davor,
da irgendwelche MPEG-2-Videos zu decoden und so, vergiss es.
Gab es jemals einen SCART-Ausgang bei Grafikkarten?
Hier war doch sowas im Prinzip.
Du hast die Dinger immer, du hast einen S-Video-Ausgang
und den hast du immer an so einen SCART-Stecker gestöpselt für den Fernseher.
Das war ja mit S-Video quasi, sowas.
RTE All in Wonder, genau.
Oh man, all die PCs hatten einen SCART-Ausgang, wirklich?
Das war ein Bild? Habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Turboknopf, ja, der Turboknopf war ja nicht zum Turbomachen,
sondern zum Gegenteil, um es langsamer zu machen.
Für alle Software und alte Spiele, die eben noch an Takt traten.
Das erste Commandos zum Beispiel, falls es noch jemand kennt,
das war so ein Strategie-Game.
Das war unspielbar auf neueren Rechnern,
weil das eben nicht nach Timern ginge, sondern nach CPU-Takt.
Da gab es so ein Map, da ist so ein Schiff über einen Fluss gefahren
und bei Commandos hast du dir immer so die Sichtkegel der Gegner angeguckt
und das Schiff ist bei meinem neuen Rechner dann halt einfach
den Fluss lang gefahren, wie als hätte es eine Sirene angehabt.
Weil das halt nach Takt gegangen ist und nicht nach irgendwelchen Timern.
Also deswegen gab es Turboknöpfe.
Aber das war in dieser Ära eigentlich schon wieder out.
In dieser Ära hatte eigentlich kaum Rechner noch Turboknöpfe.
Das war eher noch ein bisschen davor.
Borg.
Oh.
Moment, das Ding hatte sogar schon eine Onboard-Grafikkarte.
Ja, dann ist das wirklich kein Retro-Bild.
Das Ding hat Audio-Onboard, Netzwerk-Onboard, Grafikkarte-Onboard.
Das musstest du früher alles einzeln einbauen.
Das gab es auf Mainboards nicht.
Yep, Clock.
All die Rechner mit SCART.
Okay, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Aldi von 2004.
Das war schon eines der...
Ja, Medion.
Das war noch eines der neueren Aldi-Rechner.
Die hatten einen SCART-Ausgang.
Alter, Aldi, man.
Das ist ja geil, das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Grafikkarte mit fucking SCART-Ausgang, man.
Lul.
War gar kein schlechter Rechner für die damalige Zeit.
Was doch immer mit Aldi los ist.
Ja, Moment.
Jetzt hatte die Onboard-Grafikkarte, aber das bringt doch gar nichts.
Ja, das war damals immer abfuck, wenn das Ding gebootet ist.
Und Windows hatte standardmäßig keinen Driver für die Netzwerk-Karte dabei.
Das war schon kacke.
Man musste immer damals mit selbstgebrannten CDs mit Treiber rum...
Ah, das war kacke.
Oder von Disc.
Oh, das sieht aus wie so eine schöne Windows-Anwendung von 1995-Zeiten.
Was ist denn das, ein 15-Zoll-Bildschirm?
Was hat er denn da? Sieht ziemlich klein aus.
Sieht so aus, als könnte man ihn noch heben, ohne zusammenzubrechen.
JD Steel, Dankeschön.
Aha, CI-Treiber von Flobby beim Setup.
Du meinst, dass der irgendwie Festplatten und weitere Laufwerke erkennt, ja?
Das war doch im Windows-Setup so.
Drücken Sie jetzt F10 und inserten Sie die Treiber-Diskette.
Oh, guck mal. Damals hatte... Das ist schon Windows XP SP1 oder SP2 oder sowas.
Weil als Windows XP rausgekommen ist, bin ich mir relativ sicher, gab es diese...
...Windows-Firewall noch nicht.
...und kann sie auto-detektieren und installieren.
Tatsächlich hat sie die Files, die ich verfehlt hatte, aufgenommen und sogar veröffentlichte Files für einige der anderen Komponenten.
Also lasse ich es einfach sein.
Das war damals so richtig Magic mit Treibern.
Das lief und dann hast du gesagt, ah, aber da gibt es noch einen neuen Treiber, lass mal ausprobieren.
Das war so richtig Magie.
Man wusste auch nicht genau, was man da eigentlich macht.
Äh, Tomox sehe ich genauso.
Oh, MonkaS.
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich nicht an Snappy Driver, das liegt wahrscheinlich an dem Kack-Treiber, den Snappy Driver installiert hat.
Wenn der die Grafikkarte eingebaut hat, dann kann es Crysis spielen, aber nicht gut.
Nicht gut. Es kann auf jeden Fall nicht gut Crysis spielen.
Ja, genau.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, Far Cry 1 kam zu dieser Zeit raus.
Es ist heute immer noch beeindruckend, wie gut Quake 3 lief zur damaligen Zeit.
Die wussten aber damals, dass es für einen schnellen Multiplayer-Shooter essentiell ist, dass es nicht ruckelt.
Also Quake 3 lief für die Optik und was die geboten haben, lief wirklich gut.
Und Quake 3 war übrigens, by the way, meines Wissens nach, das erste Game, was runde Torbögen konnte.
Das wird man sich in der heutigen Zeit gar nicht vorstellen können, aber damals gingen in vielen 3D-Engines keine runden Flächen.
Außer halt gefakt als Textur mit Alpha-Transparenz und sowas.
Quake 3 Around Arches heißt das, glaube ich, oder?
In anderen Spielen konntest du es nur so machen.
Du konntest es halt so aus verschiedenen abgestuften Schritten kriegen.
Aber Quake 3 war das erste Game, wie man hier sieht, was richtig runde Torbögen und generell runde Objekte und sowas haben konnte in der Map.
Warte mal, ist 3DMark03 das, wo man mit dem Drache im Kreis fliegt?
Moment, 3DMarkDragonDemo?
Nee, das war 3DMark2000.
Ja, bei der Grafikdemo ging mir eine ab damals, Leute, sag ich euch.
Da ging mir richtig eine ab.
Bei dieser Dragonflight-Demo.
Ja, das war das erste.
Boah, da ging mir richtig eine ab drauf, ja.
Aber man muss sich das mal angucken.
Es sieht nicht gut aus, aber man kann es sich angucken, ja.
3D99?
Nee, an den kann ich mich gar nicht mehr erinnern.
Na ja, gucken wir weiter.
Nee, stimmt, die Radio, ja, keine Ahnung.
Lag anscheinend doch nicht da dran.
Äh, was war's vorher?
Max, zeig mal ein UT99-Video, Facing Worlds.
Das sah auch gut aus, ja, Facing Worlds ist eines der ikonischsten Karten aus Unreal Tournament.
Das war das mit den zwei Türmen auf der einen und der anderen Seite
und dann diesen zwei kleinen Wegen in der Mitte, wo man langlaufen konnte.
Genau, ja.
Ja.
Wie wär's mit ein paar bewegten Bildern dabei?
Das war auch sehr optisch sehr gut für die damalige Zeit.
Sowas können die Leute, glaube ich, heute nicht allzu viel anfangen.
Weißt, es war schon wirklich eine coole Zeit.
Du hast bei den Spielen damals auch einfach gemerkt,
die Leute haben das programmiert, was sie selbst feiern würden zum Spielen.
Ich will Unreal Tournament spielen.
Jetzt erst mal mit dem Redeemer im Nachkampf.
War der Redeemer dieses komische drehende Messerding, wo du Leute im Nachkampf messern konntest?
Ja, das stimmt.
Die wollten ja ein neues Unreal Tournament entwickeln, aber dann war Fortnite so erfolgreich.
Aber ich glaube, die Zeit von solchen Arena-Shootern wie das...
Ach, dann bring ich's dir.
Das ist vorbei. Das Interesse daran ist einfach nicht mehr da.
Ja, Crysis muss man nicht ausprobieren.
Crysis kam irgendwie Jahre später raus, als der PC gemacht wurde.
Zu der Zeit kam Far Cry 1 raus.
Blutscht.
Nee, nee, aber trotzdem mehr.
Aber nicht dreimal mehr. Das dachte ich mir.
Wir werden es in zukünftigen Episoden sehen,
denn es wird eine tolle Plattform sein, um andere Retro-PC-Teile und Akzessorien zu testen.
Retro-Mods begonnen.
Mega spannend noch und so.
War schon nice.
Jetzt wird mir schon Alexi Beksi vorgeschlagen, ich weiß es nicht.
Nix wie weg.
Werde ich im Leben nicht gucken.
Pass mal auf, YouTube-Algorithmus, please nicht mehr empfehlen.
Muss man einfach einmal anklicken und dann geht es meistens weg,
nachdem man es einmal angeklickt hat und wieder geschlossen hat.
Ja, nice, weg ist es.
Pog.
Kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Nix dagegen, wenn es jemandem gefällt.
Ich mag die Videos nicht.
Gaben vor zwölf Jahren.
Ich habe zu wenige Tabs.
Finde ich auch.
Sollte noch ein bisschen mehr sein.
Wir müssen unbedingt noch...
Was ist eigentlich mit den Shorts hier gerade wieder los?
Ja, Chat, das habe ich auch gerade gedacht.
Ah, wieder so ein schönes G-Bait-Video.
YouTube-Shorts sind komisch.
Wenn ich Shorts gucken will,
dann würde ich ja schon fast lieber auf TikTok.
Wobei ich persönlich auch nicht gerne auf TikTok gehe.
Viele YouTube-Shorts sind auch so rehashed TikTok-Videos.
Du hast bei manchen YouTube-Shorts
sogar noch das TikTok-Video unten in der Ecke.
Einfach Copy-Pasta.
Okay, Leute, schön, dass ihr da gewesen seid.
Spontaner Stream gewesen heute.
Wir sehen uns die Tage.
Vielleicht morgen Abend schon.
Morgen muss ich nach Frankfurt fahren.
Keck Business machen.
Und wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut. Bis dann.
C-E oder C-U.